- Oh
- [Kelly] Well that looked terrifying.
Congratulations on that.
- Thank you.
- Was that Madeline?
Was that Madeline that was on the phone
you were talking to also?
- Yeah. Oh, wait, that
wasn't clear, I don't think.
But yes, she's there, but she's there.
- [Kelly] It was clear.
- Okay. Okay, okay.
- Yeah. I'm terrified.
Have y'all met before today?
- Yeah. We met backstage.
- We met backstage.
She wandered into my dressing room
- I stole one of his guitars.
- And stole one of your
guitars, by the way.
- I like it.
- Yeah. Then I-
- You play?
- I do.
- You do. You love to
play, you love music?
- I do. I love to sing.
Playing is just more like a
something so that I can sing
more, you know what I mean?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I'm not, I'm bad at guitar.
- No, I am bad at guitar.
- Ooh, I dunno.
- I love that you love music so much.
Does your whole family? Do
y'all ever sing together?
- I mean yeah, we do. We really do.
- [Kelly] That's fun.
- My brother doesn't participate
because he thinks it's lame.
But my mom and my dad and me.
- [Kelly] Y'all do. I like that.
- Yeah. I mean he's like
a musician, musician.
So he doesn't wanna like do sing-alongs
with his family, you know?
- [Kelly] I'm a musician, musician.
I'll do sing-alongs.
- [Sosie] Yeah.
- [Kelly] He needs to man up.
- [Sosie] You guys are a little different.
Exactly. Like get it together, Travis.
(Kelly laughs)
- So your new movie is insane.
It's so scary.
It's, and I love that it's called "Smile"
which makes it scary.
You made the word smile wrong.
But what's it about?
So why, why'd you wanna do it?
- Okay, so it's about a woman
who has kind of suffered
some trauma in her past
and then she witnesses this event
which kind of makes her
like contend with it
while she's been trying
to ignore it, you know?
- Yeah.
- As we all end up having
to deal with our traumas
I think at some point.
And let's see,
why'd I do it you said?
- Yeah. Why'd you wanna do a horror film.
Are you into horror?
- Yeah. I love horror.
We're like a big horror
family ever since I was a kid
but it's hard to choose.
So I really wanted to do one that had like
a good meaty character
and it is definitely meaty.
It was a lot of, it was a lot of work
and super exhausting, but-
- I was like, emotionally
that must be draining.
- [Sosie] Yeah
- That kind of scene,
I was like, oh my God, how
many more were like that?
- And those were, all
the scenes are like that.
Like there's no like "ha,
ha, this is an easy one."
(Both laughing)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
So speaking of supernatural,
you do tarot card readings?
- [Sosie] I do, I do.
- I am into this as well
and it kills me that literally like
every time I've done it, it's dead on.
- [Sosie] I know. It
pretty much always is.
It's really creepy.
- Yeah, but isn't it one of those things
that you can sort of adjust?
It's like when they read
your horoscope for the day.
- [Kelly] You can see what you want.
- You can read any of those
and you could apply it
to whatever yours is.
- You can, but when I say like dead on,
I mean like literally.
- [Sosie] Right, yeah.
- What I was talking
about like last night.
Okay. Well Josh and I pulled
some cards this morning.
I was very excited. Maybe Josh wasn't.
- [Sosie] No he was.
- No, I am.
- [Kelly] Can you tell us what they mean?
- Can I get the cards? I'm so sorry.
- I remember mine.
- Okay. Alright. So.
Your's were...
you got the three of cups?
- Yeah.
- And then you also got,
this isn't a card trick, I swear.
And then you also got
judgment and the hanged man.
And this makes a lot, like, okay, so.
The three of cups is like
collaborative experiences
with platonic people in your life.
Women, usually for me it's women,
like real celebrations of like friendship
and support and love.
And then you got Judgment
and the Hanged Man,
which are big cards.
So.
Good cards,
but it feels like you're maybe
at the end of sort of a cycle.
And Judgment is very much like
allowing change to happen.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Sosie] But don't push change,
- Like sit with it, allow it.
- Okay.
- And then the Hanged
Man, to get that after,
that's like, you're
gonna be in a situation
that maybe feels uncomfortable
because it's like meditative
but you just have to
sit in the discomfort,
and like on the other side is growth
and like so much knowledge
- [Kelly] Like-
- [Sosie] Does this feel accurate?
- Insane!
- Does it feel accurate to you?
- It's insane.
- Okay. Yay!
- It's so funny because what you just said
totally applies to my life.
- Does it?
- I'm kidding.
- No wait, because wait-
wait till you see what
applies to your life.
- All right, all right.
- And also you're very in
tune with like the world
if you got Judgment 'cause we're all in
a judgment cycle right now.
But anyways.
- Okay, I wanna know yours, skeptic.
- [Sosie] Okay, Josh.
(Josh laughs)
- [Sosie] So you got the magician, fun.
- [Kelly] Ooh!
- Then you got the four of
cups, which is hilarious.
Then you got the King of Pentacles.
Okay.
- King of what?
- [Sosie and Kelly] Pentacles.
- Pentacles or tentacles?
- [Kelly] I like the magicials.
- [Sosie] Pentacles
- Pentacles. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] The magician's cool.
- All right, so the
magician is a very early
part of your journey
which is all like fire,
forward motion, excitement.
You have all of these new opportunities.
A situation is brand new and just like,
it's like a go, go, go.
All the options are open to you.
Whereas like, this is
number 12 or something,
that's one.
So you're like at the
beginning of something.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- [Josh] Okay.
- [Sosie] But by the, of something
- [Kelly] Which is crazy,
you just got married.
- Maybe this is when I start believing.
- [Sosie] I know you just got married.
- We're gonna turn you.
- [Josh] In tarot cards.
- You're lying right now.
- No. Hey!
- I can see your eyes.
- It might be the beginning.
- [Sosie] No, wait. Wait.
Then you got the Four of Cups.
Now this card cracks me up
because it's somebody
who has all these cups
but is still like this.
- Hmm.
- Yeah.
- So it's a call for gratitude
that you have a lot of like,
like a lot in your life and not like-
I get this card a lot.
- A lot of that and not enough gratitude?
- [Sosie] You could use a little bit more.
(Kelly and Josh laugh)
- Fair, fair.
- [Sosie] I get this a
lot because I'm a grumpy,
I'm so grumpy.
- I love that you kept it daytime.
- It's not a bad thing,
it's just a suggestion.
Like look at all these cups you have
and look at all this great stuff.
And then the King of Pentacles.
Pentacles rules like material.
So it's basically like you're a boss.
- I'm a what?
- A boss.
- [Josh] Oh, a boss.
- Oh a boss.
- Yeah. Like it's-
but a boss that like
really knows everything.
What you are is someone who's like,
knows it, in control
- You know what? I feel better.
- [Sosie] Really?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I feel better after
hearing you read my cards.
- Really?
- Yes.
- So you're a convert?
- Is that, are you living
in your gratitude right now?
- [Josh] I feel like, I feel like
- [Sosie] Do you feel grateful?
- I feel grateful for certain things
and I also realize I need
to work on certain things.
- [Sosie] Okay. Okay, great.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I'm happy that you're, you enjoyed it.
- I Love it, I think it's so cool.
- It wasn't just all affirmation.
It was like, it felt like it was honest.
- [Sosie] Yes.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yes, I need to tell
you the bad stuff too.
'Cause I know you can take it.
- Am I pregnant?
(Kelly laughs)
- The craziest story ever.
- Oh man, that would be awesome.